I'm fascinated by the idea of faith,
what faith means.
Uh,
Jacob listens to a voice and believes it.
Um,
he probably heard other voices.
Why did he believe this one?
Um,
why,
what,
there must have been an a priori sort of functional necessity for him to believe
the voice that told him one thing or another.
And,
and I think that that's a string that runs through the Bible and then through
the New Testament,
I'm,
we are expected as well.
I confess I'm a Christian,
I'm,
I act like I believe God is real.
And,
and so there is this a call of faith and also the,
in every hero's story we,
we see now there is always a moment in that story where the hero must believe
something beyond the evidence that is before them,
which is to say they must take a leap of faith.
So I'm wondering if you could just kind of unpack that experience of faith and
the understanding of how a human being makes the choice to believe one thing or
another.
God,
that's a great question.
I mean,
I,
is this still on,
is this still working?
Good.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Um,
I don't,
I don't precisely know the answer that it's a very peculiar thing because we
think many things,
or you could say many voices appear in our minds because when Nisha took day
cards,
I think therefore I am a part can you said,
well,
it isn't so obvious that there's an eye,
first of all that it's a unity,
like a not our tra unity transparent unto itself,
which of course the psychoanalysts picked up in a big way and then he wasn't
sure that it was the eye who thought in some causal manner.
He said,
well no,
it's more like thoughts.
It's something like thoughts appear in the phenomenal field and maybe you choose
between the more maybe they possess you.
Like there's lots of other ways of thinking about it.
It isn't exactly obvious to me why we choose to take one pathway rather than
another when so many of them could offer themselves to us.
You know,
people tend to talk about that as something like conscience,
right?
And now maybe it's that
it's got to have something to do.
I think it's an endless regress because you can always ask why the,
why any assumption became primary.
But I'll put that aside for a moment.
It seems to me to have something to do with your aims.
You know,
that you're more likely to listen to a voice that is in keeping with your most
fundamental aims.
And then the question is,
where do your most fundamental aims come from?
And from what I've been able to determine it,
I'll speak psychologically again,
is that to begin with,
you're a con can't tonation of rather primitive subpersonalities Hungary,
one's tired ones upset one's laughing ones.
You can see that in babies,
you know,
they cycle through those states very rapidly.
There's a,
uh,
infantile unity above all that,
but it doesn't have control,
right?
And so then the developing individual has to figure out how to integrate those
primitive subpersonalities into a unified personality.
At the same time,
they integrate the unified personality into a social unity.
So it's partly individual integration,
but it's fed by social forces.
I mean even when you watch an infant breastfeed,
it's established a relationship with its mother and there's a reciprocity that's
already at play there.
So then that underlying multiplicities starts to form itself into a unity.
And then the question,
and I would say that's something like that's something like the emergence of
the,
the individual out of,
out of the the titans.
That's a reasonable way of thinking about it.
Like a sovereign out of the titans.
It's something like that.
But then there's another division which seems to me to parallel parallel the the
cane enabled division.
It's that that integration can be oriented towards something that's positive,
but it can also be oriented towards something that's negative and that's the
split of the world into good and evil I think.
And then it looks like you're navigating between those and I can only account
for that with something like choice,
like I think the free choice,
even though I don't understand it,
I'm unwilling to deny the existence of free choice merely because I don't
understand it because it looks to me like that's how people act.
That's how the expect to be treated.
And that societies who,
that that structure themselves in accordance with the idea that people have free
choice actually work.
Now that doesn't prove that there's free choice,
but people have been arguing about that forever.
So,
but it looks to me,
so those are two possible means of integration.
And then I think what you're doing is feeding one or the other constantly.
And I think you probably choose which one to feed.
I think that's,
and I mean that's how it feels that way to me as well.
Like when I look at my own,
you know,
maybe you're really aggravated with something,
maybe you're aggravated with your wife,
you know,
or or,
or your child or something like that,
you know,
and you're feeling kind of nasty and maybe even know that you're in the wrong
and an idea comes into your head.
You think I could say that.
And you know,
you could say it and you know what it would do,
but then you pause and you think,
would that make it better or worse?
And then maybe you go to hell with it,
which is quite the thing to say.
I've got a little story about in a minute,
and then you say it,
but you knew,
you knew that you took the low road,
right?
And you know it,
and then you're guilty about that and defensive.
And that makes the fight way worse because then there's no damn way you're going
to admit that you actually did that.
And so things do go to hell.
And so,
so here's,
here's an ugly little idea.
So that's,
that's,
that's relevant to the question.
So imagine you're playing around with cocaine.
Now I'm using cocaine because it's very addictive,
but it's a very interesting chemical because it's a dopaminergic agonist.
And what,
what dopamine does is two things.
It makes you feel like what you're doing is worthwhile,
but it also imagine that there's a bunch of neural circuits that are active and
then they get a hit of dopamine or you do,
then those neurocircuits get a little bit more powerful.
Okay?
So it,
it has a rewarding property,
which is that it makes you feel like what you're doing is important and it has a
reinforcing property,
which is,
it makes neurocircuits growth.
So now what that means is that
whatever you were doing just before you took cocaine grows.
Okay?
So now imagine there's a bunch of different things that you do just before you
take cocaine,
but there's a string of decisions.
And it one decision point is the same for all of those difference occurrences.
And that decision point is because you know you're in trouble.
And that decision point is well,
to hell with it.
Okay?
So then you think that each of the 200 times that you take cocaine,
even though you do it in different places,
but that one thought is there all the time.
And that thing grows because you're reinforcing it and it grows and it grows and
it grows.
And so now that's in you.
Let's,
that's part of you.
And it's the thing that says to hell with it.
Okay,
so now,
and maybe that's not such a good thing to grow inside your brain.
So then you,
you're addicted and they take you to a cocaine treatment center.
And after a week,
you're no longer physically,
physiologically addicted.
You're not craving.
You don't have a problem as long as you're there.
But then they take you back to your normal environment and you see like cocaine,
Joe,
your friend.
And as soon as you see him up,
that thing comes in,
Bang,
you're back on the,
you're back on the to hell with the track.
And that's where you're in,
where you will end up too if you reinforce that particular perspective long
enough.
So that's a,
in a sense to the,
this decision making process.
You know,
if you,
if you take the low road,
then that winds and it gets a little stronger because everything that wins
neurologically gets a little stronger.
It's like a Darwinian competition.
So one rule is don't practice what you don't want to become because you really
do become that.
It builds,
it builds itself right into your neural architecture.
And that's one of the terrifying things about addiction,
you know,
because you think,
well,
it's kind of psychological.
It's like,
yeah,
kind of.
It's also kind of neurophysiological and you build a one eyed cocaine monster in
your head if you hit yourself enough with something that reinforcing.